claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison le coronavirus est ce
qu'on peut parler d'un test pour la
chine tout le monde évidemment va
scruter comment ce pays gère cette
épidémie est fait évidemment tout le
monde regarde comment les gens chinois
traitent la question et notamment en
comparant avec le traitement en 2003 du
strass et de ce point de vue évidemment
d'abord il faut dire que la chine n'est
plus la même chine 17 ans plus tard
c'est une chine tout à fait différente
qui s'est beaucoup développée et puis
dans le le patron et si jean ping qui
veut se montrer efficace alors il a
d'ailleurs dit ce qui est très important
il a déclaré qu' il ne fallait pas que
les fonctionnaires locaux fasse de la
rétention d'information pour défendre je
ne sais quel intérêt local et qu'il
fallait que l'information soit ouverte
autrement dit que tout le monde soit
transparent par ailleurs il a pris des
décisions très très très très rapide
pour faire construire des hôpitaux alors
sur les hôpitaux de campagne bien sûr
pour soigner les chinois qui sont
infectés par le ver hills ou qui
pourraient l'être et on voit qu'il a
pris les choses en main d'ailleurs le
directeur général de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé qui était à pékin
il ya deux jours au début de la semaine
trois jours lui a donnés à une sorte de
satisfecit en disant que la chine
faisait tout ce qu'il fallait faire pour
endiguer cette épidémie
alors si la communauté internationale
estime que le gouvernement chinois n'en
a pas fait assez
est ce que par hasard la chine pourrait
être sanctionné le sanctionner elle va
l'être nécessairement sur le plan
économique puisque toutes les opinions
publiques
dans tous les pays du monde demandent à
leur gouvernement de prendre des mesures
quelles mesures prenez vous pour
protéger nos nationaux et par conséquent
cela veut dire que des mesures sont
prises par pratiquement tous les
gouvernements pour soit rapatrié les
nationaux soit coupé les liaisons
aériennes avec la chine est évidemment
ceci aura des conséquences sur
l'activité économique en chine
on dit même que probablement la chine
perdra un point de croissance
si cette épidémie eux durent quelques
mois comme c'est vraisemblable
alors on vient de le voir et vous venez
de nous lire le directeur de l' oms qui
était en chine l'om est-ce qui a décidé
à l'instant de déclarer l'urgence
internationale ça aussi ça peut avoir
des conséquences claires sur sur la
chine bien sûr alors j'allais dire enfin
parce que effectivement si ce que
l'opinion publique internationale
demandait et on a même eu on a même dit
que la chine avait tout fait pour
freiner cette opération en début de
semaine vrai ou faux peu importe
en tout cas maintenant c'est fait et en
effet ceci a des conséquences et crée
des obligations pour tous les pays dans
lesquels le l'épidémie peut se dévêt
susceptible de se développer
et effectivement je crois qu'il faut
dans une un cas de ce genre que la
coopération internationale joue son rôle
une coopération médicale une coopération
scientifique
les chinois ont transmis très tôt toutes
les données sur le virus et sur le
séquençage adn eu du virus alors que ça
n'avait pas été le cas en 2003 pour le
strass il faut qu'une coopération
internationale et dans le fond il ne
faut pas jouer un petit jeu géopolitique
d'un pays contre un autre or vous paraît
effectivement de la confiance qu'on peut
avoir dans ce pays
vous l'avez dit on peut lire plein de
choses partout est-ce qu'on peut
clairement faire confiance à la chine
certains articles de presse un qu'on ne
citera pas disait voilà ils
sous-estiment les chiffres à ce que
aulas évidemment vous n'avez pas là la
vérité
est-ce qu'on peut être là dedans on peut
avoir confiance selon vous désormais
écoutées
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement
chinois ne veut pas tomber sous cette
critique l'a remis la ilaha illa et il a
fait l'objet d'une critique très très
sévère en 2003 sur son traitement du
strass et je crois qu'il est attaché
en effet à la transparence des
informations en chine à la coopération
internationale et à la coopération
d'autres notamment à travers
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
mais bien sûr on n'empêchera pas les
faits que news de circuler moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que quand on interroge des
médecins et on en voit beaucoup sur les
chaînes de radio et les chaînes de
télévision généralement ils ont plutôt
un ton ratures ont bien sûr c'est très
sérieux il faut prendre la chose au
sérieux
bien sûr il faut isoler les individus
qui sont contaminés et puis il faut les
traiter
mais dans le fond l'avis des médecins
c'est que ça n'est pas encore une grande
pandémie mondiale
alors il n'empêche ikea ferme tous ses
magasins en chine certains pays
rapatrient leurs ressortissants on l'a
vu air france suspend ses vols
est ce qu'il ya une sorte de mise à
l'écart est effectivement de la chine
aujourd'hui je pense que il ya un effet
d'entraînement
les pilotes d'air france ont fait voter
une motion pour dire après tout british
airways iberia et la lufthansa et et
leurs filiales supprime tous les vols
pourquoi escale france le fait pas donc
air france ce finalement l'a fait elle a
décidé cet après midi je crois qu'il ya
un effet d'entraînement en effet est il
actuellement les grandes entreprises
sont aussi amenés à rappeler leur leurs
ressortissants à les faire revenir à la
maison
peut-être aussi pour se mettre à l'abri
d'éventuels recours parce qu'après tout
un employé français pourraient se
retourner contre son entreprise est une
entreprise contre l'état qui n'ont pas
facilité le retour à la maison
donc chacun joue du principe de
précaution
la russie elle qui ferment carrément ses
frontières avec la chine c'est une
nécessité là encore une obligation c'est
un pays voisin il ya une frontière en
effet comme on l'a dit à votre reportage
de katniss 250 km considérable la
mongolie a pris la même mesure
et effectivement je faudra voir comment
concrètement cette mesure est appliquée
parce que les quatre nuls et quatre
mille 250 km ne sont pas surveillées
mètre par mètre c'est totalement
impossible donc dans l'immédiat le
mystère affaires étrangères de russie a
dit qu'il ne devrait plus y aller il n'y
aurait plus de délivrance de visas
automatique ni à la frontière pour les
chinois qui se présente puisque cette
procédure était possible ni à moscou ni
à saint pétersbourg pour les chinois qui
viendraient en visite professionnelle ou
ou touristiques
alors pour le reste le contrôle de la
frontière c'est probablement une autre
affaire merci beaucoup claude da
blanchemaison nous avoir apporté votre
analyse merci à vous